Cuántas veces en la vida nos Han dicho que no se puede.
Nos Han dicho
que no se puede tener 1 trabajo y tener hijos a la vez.
Nos Han dicho también
que es muy difícil montar 1 negocio que no lo hagas,
que no se puede.
Nos Han dicho que los españoles no tenemos remedio,
que nunca nos daremos la mano
para mirar al futuro juntos.
Pero claro que se puede.
Que te lo digan a ti,
que levantas cada día a tu familia
contra viento y marea,
o a ti que has montado 1 proyecto
frente a todos los obstáculos y toda la burocracia,
o aquellos que Han encontrado 1 Nuevo trabajo
o aquellos que habéis superado
1 grave enfermedad.
Dicen que los españoles no podemos,
pero yo creo que sí que se puede.
Es lo que me enseñaron mis padres
y es lo que le quiero enseñar a mis hijos.
Si quieres cambiar las cosas, claro que se puede.
Si eres liberal, vota liberal,
si eres de Centro, vota al Centro.
Si eres valiente, vota valiente.
No votes con miedo, ni con odio, ni con resignación.
Vota con ilusión,
vota con ganas a quien más te guste.
Vote con la cabeza y vota con el corazón.
Vota lo que sientes,
vota lo que eres.
Vota ciudadanos